what is the data telling us about this
new variant omicron well i'm afraid the
bad news is not that much right now we
don't know much about its virulence
about precisely how transmissionable it
is and even the data we do have i'm
going to show you some of it there are
some question marks over that we'll
start with this chart you might have
seen it around there it's just comparing
different variants in south africa and
how quickly they grew to become a big
percentage of the total so you've got a
percentage of the total there that's
beta that was the old south african
variant uh last winter then you've got
delta so earlier on this year and here's
omicron
looks pretty scary doesn't it a really
steep increase in comparison to these
other two things but here's the thing
that chart depends on a key judgment
which is where do you start those lines
is it when they surpass one percent of
all of the cases or is it when they
surpass another number and if you do it
for instance uh when it surpasses five
percent of all cases pretty reasonable
thing to do look at how those lines
change it's exactly the same data but it
just shows you while omicron's certainly
very steep it doesn't look quite so out
of whack uh with the others nonetheless
that is transmissibility
but here's the thing that's only based
on a relatively small sample pool
there's not all that much covered well
it's rising in south africa but there
wasn't a few weeks ago comparison with
previous times and you get that sense if
you just look at absolute numbers so
again it's from the same data set we're
just looking at the absolute numbers of
detections here so that's beta and we're
going back to last year here so you can
see that's around the winter time then
you've got delta happening in the summer
the late summer in south africa and now
look at omicron these are just absolute
number of detections of samples of
vomicron and you can see it really is
quite small it's only about 100 samples
that we have so far now what have we
learned through covid we've learned that
those small lines can get high very
quickly when you've got exponential
growth which is what happens with covert
especially if this variant is more
transmission well that could go up
really quickly indeed but for the time
being we're basing this off a small
sample pool just we need to be cautious
because we don't know for sure what's
going on here and crucially we don't
know what's going to happen with this
chart remember this relationship this is
cases in the uk and you can see spike
last winter so very big increase last
winter and now they are really high at
the moment so cases of covered now have
a look at death so red line here showing
you deaths it's on a different axis so
that line is actually a lot smaller but
i'm just putting them next to each other
so you can see a real relationship a
correlation last winter but that
correlation has broken down you've got a
divergence and cases are high but
death's comparatively low compared with
previous periods and the big question
now is whether that remains the case for
omicron